[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for another
tip 2019 interview right now we have the
team behind the upcoming Animated
Feature abominable Here I am so excited
about this movie I haven't seen it yet
but I was reading all the press notes
and it just seems like this is gonna be
a really fun adventure but with some
real heart and personal meaning behind
it and I am just so excited to dig into
that I wanted to start with you here
second feature film as a director is
there anything you learned on your first
one that you said like I got to do this
this way on abominable I think what I
learned the most going on the first on
my first movie which was open season
this movie I got to write in direct and
so it was a little more personal and I I
really think it's important to be
collaborative with the studio but also
to fight for the things that are very
important to the movie that you really
believe in the things that you connect
to if you don't fight for those things
then I feel like your your vision gets
compromised and so I really fought hard
to keep a lot of core things in this
movie and I'm really proud of it at this
point you've worked with a whole bunch
of the really great animated Studios out
there do you know like maybe something
about all of them that stays consistent
something that really makes a great
animated studio that's a great question
I think all I've been very fortunate
that all of the companies I've worked
for strive for two things that are very
important to them story is first they
will not let projects out until the
story is just right the other thing is
quality and I think anytime you have you
know there's varying degrees of quality
and sometimes that comes with a price
tag but I feel like I've been incredibly
spoiled and our film abominable looks so
rich so lush so beautiful and that has a
lot to do with the team itself and the
commitment by our studio DreamWorks and
Pearl to have the highest level of
quality now for the three of you here is
it a first-time voicing a character in
an animated feature for all three of you
for me it is okay I did a few things I
did a few little things but I wouldn't
this is definitely like a completely
different experience you know knowing
how so
working with DreamWorks is you're just
working with the best of the best and
this team that made you know abominable
is its it it oozes just craftsmanship in
every aspect of the film and it's
something I was relatively ignorant to
before really working on the film and
you see how much effort and how much
just artistry is goes into every frame
of the film everything that you're here
everything and obviously working with
Jill was incredible because immediately
we got on right right away and we just
had so much in common and it's it's just
was like an incredible experience it was
the most one of the most fun I've ever
had working on anything is there
anything about voicing a character in an
animated feature that kind of surprised
you something about the process that
made you think oh I didn't realize
that's how they did it well for me voice
over is very different from like
live-action from like filming something
like a TV show or movie normally because
it you don't see anything all you have
is the script when you start the project
and when you're recording you don't have
any of the animation or like your
characters or sets or anything so you
basically have to imagine everything so
that really was what surprised me yeah I
think the same for me you don't really
get to do your scene with the people
that are actually in the scene with you
I mean Jill is a great actress don't get
me wrong but it's definitely different
from live-action and it's it's
surprisingly not as easy as as people
say because you have to get all this
emotion by just standing in front of a
microphone it's I would say it's almost
harder than actual yeah everyone you
know the big thing is like you could
just show up in your pajamas and show up
into work and I'm like if you think I'm
gonna go to DreamWorks Studios in there
like giant amazing campus in pajamas and
work as a professional in that I
wouldn't do that and also it's the the
level of imagination and in even with
like logistic things like am i turning
around is the character turning around
at this point how far are they from from
you are you when do you start walking
and then does the
[ __ ] like there's like technical things
that you don't that are so already
inherent when you're on screen and when
you're doing live-action and so there
was it required a lot a lot of a lot
more imagination than you would then you
and expect it's also exhausting the
efforts are very difficult to the are
called efforts yeah referred to them as
efforts in another interview once and
someone looked at me like I had three
heads and I'm like oh no you know it's
it's worse thing too it's just that
these guys show up and we're in a
recording booth for hours and hours and
hours and without a set without hair and
makeup it's just about acting and so
when that's what has impressed me so
much about this group is that it
requires such vulnerability to go to
this place and think about yourself as
this character and just disappear into
the character you have nothing else like
look how gorgeous these people are they
you you know none of this you can hide
behind it's all about your pure acting
but human suppose was how much support
you gave at least me and I you know I I
know I feel I could speak for everyone
here is she's so incredible an you have
such a cool the the we're spoiled and
getting to work with you because you've
such a knowledge of the script and you
also have a knowledge of the fact that
there's different things that you didn't
think of or like that you were like oh
that's even better like this or like
that's you're so giving and thoughtful
with like your ideas and time and how to
kind of cuz it is a very vulnerable
thing and ultimately she's just like
nurtures every idea and like and face it
just it was she's incredible to work
with super collaborative yeah yeah it's
great
and also have the ability to kind of be
flexible in the booth because there's so
many departments this takes so many
years to actually get up on the big
screen are you able to you know and we
ever have a little fun you know what's
fun is that I think this is a strange
thing but when you're the writer you can
throw your lines out very easily you're
not Precious about them or sometimes I
should say maybe people are overly
Precious about it but I have to say when
you're creating these characters these
guys all become part of creating the
character so we don't just say like here
GE just become me Chloe
Tenzing and albert and i we all would
kind of workshop the line so we try it
one way try it another way and then it
sometimes they would riff and say
something really funny I'm like say that
do that again
and it just helped to create a stronger
more well-rounded character that really
suits them yeah that's actually one of
my favorite parts of doing voiceover and
being in this film is that we kind of
got to play around with it because
nothing was set in stone yet nothing had
been like animated yet that's a very
rare thing that yes it's a very Jill
thing because a lot that's it's usually
really not like that and it it speaks to
like the quality of the project and it
speaks to someone you have trust in in
every department that we like that
ultimately like the collaboration
knowing how clear your vision is and you
being so grounded in your vision and
confident in what you want then that
gives room it's really when you end up
working with people who are more
insecure about the work and not quite
sure what they want to do that
ultimately it becomes a more stifling
environment and Jill was it was the
opposite of that like this project was
incredible we've set the bar very very
earlier today we had another wonderful
ensemble that really just appreciated
the work that their director did in the
collaboration in that kind of
environment so I really do love hearing
about stuff like that when you're in the
booth with them acting opposite them do
you have a favorite character to perform
yourself you know what's funny I never
think about performing like it's weird
when you're bouncing off these guys most
of the time I'm only listening to them
and so it's it it I say the line but I'm
like almost just waiting for that one
where I'm like that's it and it's I'm
gonna point to Tenzing with this Tenzing
kind of hangs out he's very cool and
he'll read through the stuff and we'll
do a read-through and then when he's on
he just looks straight at me and like
said the line says the line he's like so
intense about it and I just love it
because it's sometimes it even takes me
off-guard you're so like in the moment
and so it I think the fun part about it
is I am just so about them in that room
you know I want to be their support and
we're looking for perfect lines and I
also think it's the director's job to
make these guys look good you know what
I mean I it's it's a high priority for
me to make sure that I get the best
performance out of them so that they
shine so that's so rare I just have to
say that I just think that's incredibly
rare and it's like it was such a special
experience to get to work with one of
the things that really struck me reading
up about the movie is one beat that said
that ye expresses herself through her
violin and I think we all have something
like that and it's really important so
for all of you what what is your violin
what's the way that you know you turn to
to express yourself when maybe you're
having a difficult time with something I
I mean I would say lucky enough like
it's acting and it's it's it's our job
which is a really and it's honestly
projects like this because these are the
these are the projects you you would do
for free
these are the project these are the
experiences that where you grow as
someone who's creative you grow as a
person
ye the character in general was
something was very similar to me as a
kid and you know I've been in LA for a
decade now and even in the business and
you get jaded and you get it you get a
certain way and this character in this
movie and working with Jill and the
studio has really been incredibly just
you just go oh that's the you that came
here remember that and that was a huge
that was a huge part of why this film
means a lot to me it's worth saying just
the collaboration with Chloe since she
is the main character one of the things
that was really special for me is that
when I wrote this character it was a
character who is a headstrong teenager
with their own opinions who really
drives the movie who's a tomboy and I
grew up watching Princess movies and it
was I had no role models that were like
that so I really wanted to create that
but Chloe had the same exact experience
and so we really bonded over that
character because we just feel like that
doesn't exist for kids like us so that
was a really special thing that we got
to share I bet for you to anything you
turn to like a hobby or something that
really helps you express yourself or
fills a void I mean for me it
is acting I love acting and comedy and
yeah it's just what I do every day which
is really great I'm really grateful for
it I would say acting as well I also
love making people laugh I think that's
that's my defense mechanism it I just
make a joke even if it's not the right
time or the right place it's just I just
can't help myself I love making people
laugh - that's one of my favorite things
always good to have people like that all
right
before we have to wrap up I want to play
a round of Collider most memorable with
you guys so I've got something like six
or seven topics here first thing that
comes to your mind when I say this thing
all right lady you're your most
memorable Festival premiere or movie
premiere in general I would say this one
for me yeah this one definitely this is
definitely the biggest thing that's yeah
a lighter one what is your most
memorable meal meal oh my god how do i
narrow every meal down what is the one
thing that sticks in your mind I always
love a Thanksgiving I know we're in
Toronto but I love a Thanksgiving meal
and then my favorite is like second
dinner like a warmed up once you like
nap after you eat Thanksgiving and then
you like go back and you make a bowl of
like all of the things and then you just
paint yourself even more honestly the
first thing that came to my mind was was
the chicken wings that I had last night
for dinner hotel she said the first
thing that came to my no I don't know
I'm really a fitting so I like every
meal but um I don't know I like birthday
dinners Christmas holidays all that yeah
smart choices right their most memorable
school moment oh I am in like fifth
grade I was I wrote a musical I just
decided to do this and then I'm held
auditions in the girls bathroom and
ultimately cast myself as the lead you
are ready for this
sign of times yeah I remember holding
the auditions and I was like I think
it'll be me I did a school play like a
like a musical when I was in second
grade and I think that kind of like
sparked my interest in acting so
probably that what was the play it was
always based on this children's book
called like flats family yeah my cousins
Sophie they're Flat Stanley all right
that's a big flash Stanley to the the
Avengers end game premiere and I feel
like that was my greatest achievement as
a big cousin that kids probably the
coolest kid in the school now
my greatest school memory is probably my
fifth-grade culmination I'd say it's
like the first graduation that I ever
had you know yet you got to walk down
you got to dress up and so I'd say that
can you say can you say a bad memory if
it sticks out yeah you can right I
walked across the territory of those
kids that hang out on the back field and
smoke and they surrounded me and they
were gonna totally beat me up or worse
this is junior high take me to the
bathroom and do a swirly which is like
stick your head in the toilet flush it
and I was terrified and then out of this
group of Mean Girls one of them said and
her name was Darla I'll never forget it
Darla stepped out and she saved me and
she was like come on you guys and she
took put her arm around me and walked me
back to my class give it up for the
Darla yeah darling that's like a bully
in the movies she should be I'm gonna
write her into something
with most memorable rap gift first ever
there for the series drive of shield
they gave every single crewmember like a
full bike with a with the shield logo on
it
I left mine there I'm just remembering
that I left mine on set because if we
had the wrap anyway but yeah yeah I for
a few of my classmates I wrote them a
letter and then cut a piece of my hair
and taped it to the letter because it's
that's really weird and then I lost
those letters so my hair is just putting
on my most memorable wrap gift is
probably I got to make my own action
figure on Liv and Maddie the producers
John Beck Ron Hart they took us to this
one place where you'd stand and then
it'd take a bunch of pictures around you
and it'd make a 3d figure of you which
is pretty cool there was this one time
on one of my shows where we like we
wrapped the gifts ourselves where we did
like this like assembly up because it
was right around Christmas we wrapped
around Christmas and we like kind of
like made we like wrapped them up
ourselves like like kind of like you
know how those like Christmas wrapped
gift gift wrapping stations so that was
kind of cool I guess that yeah they're
all wrapping good yeah yeah something
different yeah all right let's get one
more in all right let's go with a big
one what is the most memorable scene
you've ever shot yeah I have one okay um
the most memorable scene in this movie
that we shot is one that takes place in
the bamboo grove and it takes place
between Khloe's character ye and
Tenzin's character jin and she is
talking about how much the violin means
to her and that it's her dad's and we
rewrote the scene quite a few times but
we went into the studio and usually
record quite a few sequences at a time
and we did this one sequence probably 23
times and workshop it where we we again
like kind of changed the Lions twists
the lines and he's telling this
beautiful story about her dad and
finally in the end
after like 23 times I said Chloe just
throw the paper away just tell the story
like you tell it and she stammered a
little with her words she's kind of
stuttered and you could feel the
character and Chloe really feeling that
she had tears in her eyes I had tears in
my eyes and it is an amazing sequence to
look for yeah that one was amazing the
shoot it was also the only one where we
worked together but it was that was that
was a really awesome definitely I
remember seeing that one that one turned
out really good I saw you guys record
that one yeah it was so vulnerable both
of them and again like as a director I
feel so privileged that they are willing
to go there with me I mean we're not
there alone there's a booth full of
people in the back too and sometimes
it's hard to just let yourself go into a
bubble and let yourself really feel the
emotions honestly like in that scene in
how we shot that was actually pretty
emblematic of the kind of the theme of
the movie and that you it's it's all
about not being perfect and kind of
figuring that out and being okay with
that and ultimately finding home and
home is being happy and learning about
herself and kind of the uce go through
this journey to find herself a little
bit and find her her relationship with
her family and you know as a as a
teenager you don't she'd you know it's
not about having the perfect answer to
why you feel this way it's about I don't
I don't know why I feel that way you
know that's a big I think relatable
thing for a lot of young women they got
young boys and so getting to just kind
of experience the organic nature of that
and like see it with the film it really
worked
yeah do you want to add a most memorable
scene well when I was when I was nine I
filmed it I was on a show and one of the
episodes was based on my character's
birthday and so there was this like huge
like Aladdin like it was a Latin themed
and like we had all these costumes and
we did this like big dance number so I
think that was one of my most memorable
special is online it's like on YouTube
someone put it on you can plug it here
in the below and we know what I'm
watching I'd have to agree with Jill and
Chloe that sequence in the bamboo forest
is probably the most memorable scene
that I did in this movie maybe in my
whole acting career I guess it was
really cool to watch Chloe do what she
did and Jill allowed us to go off the
script she gave us like the rough
outline of what this group what the
scene was supposed to be and then we
just went from there and it was I
thought it was really cool yeah it's a
really nice answer and I got distracted
cuz a dog walked by wearing knee-high
socks did anyone see that that was crazy
yes colorful knee-high socks anyway
reminded me how disappointed I am in
myself that I didn't bring up dogs
during this because I read the dogs were
a big influence but I just got the raps
and I could talk about dogs all day so
I'm gonna say a huge thank you for your
attention
I'm so excited for the movie abominable
in theaters September 27th before we say
goodbye we have to say a huge thank you
to our wonderful sponsor who makes all
these interviews at TIFF 2019 happen
it's Nordstrom Canada a huge thanks to
you and to everybody out there for
watching this interview please do not
leave without liking and sharing and
we're gonna see you soon with more
coverage from Toronto International Film
Festival 2019